deshaun Watson was in the medical tent
on a couple of different occasions on
Monday night he took a hit to the knee
going into the end zone there with
Wright later their lower back there it
is an elbow to the knee and on tonyia
that is going to be painful yeah and it
is not a lot there's no protection on
that name
Frank guys don't like to be restricted
that's part of the fearlessness of
football they do not want those knee
pads covering up the knee because they
can't run as fast as they want to what a
shot that is yeah there he goes right
over the top of the of the pylon and
into the end zone and he lifts a little
bit but he shook it off and he was okay
how he felt when he rolled out of bed on
Tuesday we don't know remember last year
we had a rib injury we didn't know how
bad it was he'd take a bus to
Jacksonville because he couldn't fly in
a plane because that's how bad his ribs
were and that they were thinking about
him having to take a bus from Houston to
Denver but by then the the rib injury
healed but this guy is fearless
this guy will do whatever it takes to
play he will find a way but at some
point your body's gonna give out on you
and that's my concern for deshaun Watson
at this point Bill O'Brien the coach of
the Texans said Tuesday that it's just
normal bumps and bruises like every
player in the game has but it's only
week one you got 15 more games Chris and
I worry about the Shawn Watson having
another serious injury I worry about a
non-contact ACL tear like we saw two
years ago when it turned out that he had
injured his knee against Seattle
Seahawks four days earlier right I'm
very concerned with it I mean first off
the Shawn Watson he just did we cannot
he cannot continue to play this way the
Texans are gonna have to protect him
from himself to a degree it's just too
much I mean there's just too many car
crashes for a quarterback and a guy like
you said who's tough as hell but not
real big I mean you know we've been
around deshaun Watson what do you think
he weighs Mike 220 pounds right around
that range right and it's it's not even
about the sacks either it's about some
of the other plays man the game-winning
touchdown that it looked like it was
going to be the game-winning touchdown
pass I mean the shot he takes as he
throws the ball off with a blitzing guy
off the edge it's just a lot of those
plays as well let alone the ones he runs
and this is hey you made the point I
mean
first of all this is New England down
there in Houston they're not gonna tell
you crap about the injury and this is
one thing I just look at because
nothing's being said about the knee and
the guy limped for the last two and a
half quarters so there's something wrong
with the knee and the fact that
something is not said in the quote by
Bill well Brian again we ran that play
on fourth down and he kind of got
flipped in the air he just landed oh
yeah he just landed so there's nothing
said there about the knee - which makes
anything there's definitely an issue
with the knee the fact that that's not
said we saw him limp around he didn't
want to get up after the touchdown for a
minute or two because I think he was
sitting there going oh gosh I I hope I'm
not hurt and he was just kind of wishing
and trying to wiggle out the pain a
little bit but I would think we're gonna
hear more about this as the week goes on
injury reports Wednesday Thursday and
Friday and we don't get much information
but we will get an indication whether or
not he's injured even if he fully
participates in practice knee will be
disclosed if there is a knee injury now
obviously teams do take liberties from
time to time the standard is very low
for compliance but this is something to
watch and it's only one game done with
15 to go can he stay healthy I was
impressed his rookie year with his
ability when he decided to run to keep
his body in the right spot and avoid
taking the big hit but behind the line
of scrimmage yes I've got the hole up so
I and that that's where he's gonna get
injured not necessarily running the ball
although he was diving into the end zone
the other night it's it's I worry about
him when the pocket collapses right on
top of his like a wall falls on yeah I
think that's your you're right Mike I
mean hit running normally he's pretty
good at it avoiding the big hits the
only time you see him when he runs and
gets in some big collisions is when he's
down by the goal line like remember the
Dallas game last year you know down
there he took some big hits because he's
he's sacrificing at all to get in the
end zone and that's gonna happen I
understand that but you're right it's
the pocket passes him holding the ball
to the very last second and just getting
wiped out that really scares me about
his game whether he can continue to go
on like this
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports